if you're following me on Twitter I am a
supporter of Israel I believe that the
Jewish people have a right to
self-determination just like every other
people including the Palestinian people
by the way and I've been hearing a lot
of crazy stuff and and misinformation
I've been sort of disappointed by people
on my side of the aisle
because it seems to me that Israel is
the one country in that part of the
world that stands up for all the things
that we talked about here all the time
in terms of women's rights and gay
rights and economic equality and science
and medical marijuana and all kinds of
other stuff but before we get into any
of that and I know the Nazis are already
commenting on YouTube love you guys
I want to throw up a map of the Middle
East so I googled map of the Middle East
and here's what came up so this is the
first map of the Middle East if you just
google map of the Middle East this is
the first thing that comes up now people
seem to think that the
israeli-palestinian conflict is the
source of all the world's problems and
it's a huge thing that is causing
consternation all over the place now
what we are we really talking about guys
do you know where Israel is there
because that's the Middle East what it
doesn't say Israel on there do you know
where it might be on there by any chance
I happen to know where it is yeah it is
just a real little cashew sized sliver
right there on the coast right so that
little tiny thing between Syria and
Egypt now again this is the first map
when you google map in the Middle East
so then I wanted to zoom in on it so I
clicked it so then here we go with the
second one and then it actually zoomed
you out whatever you okay so there so
there it is now if you look in the
centre of the thing a little bit above
Egypt to the right you can see Israel
and you can't even fit one letter of the
word Israel on the map now yes
that means Gaza and the West Bank or
even smaller than that but that's just
where I wanted to start to kind of show
everybody that when we're talking about
this area of the world that we're
talking about this tight ridiculously
tiny piece of land it maybe that's what
makes the real-estate all the more
valuable but I have a feeling that
people seem to think that it's this
massive ever-expanding country okay so I
want to just I'm going to do just one
minute sort of defense of Israel so you
know there was something called the the
partition plan the UN Partition Plan in
1947 and this is
where the UN said we're gonna give two
states to two people the Jews said yes
the Arabs said no and then launched a
war and had there not been Israeli win
in the war there would have been a
second Holocaust right there this is
this is simply a fact then in 2005 so
I'm gonna just kind of jump all over
place and that's it
so 2005 the Israelis left Gaza they left
altogether not one Jew there again
Hitler would have loved the place
there was no blockade by the way and but
then for two years they were Hamas won
an election they ended up having a
bloody coup over Fatah so mokmou de bas
who's the president of the Palestinian
Authority he literally does not step
foot in Gaza because he's afraid he
would get killed so think about that
they've been negotiating over this land
where one of the guys negotiating is
afraid to step in part of the land that
he's supposed to control that's a bit of
a problem then Hamas took over they were
importing Rockets firing rockets and
then the blockade happened and by the
way the BOK aid is also happening from
Egypt in many cases much worse from
Egypt because they're not letting
anything in Israel is supplying Wi-Fi
and electricity and food and supplies in
blah blah blah okay
so people always talk about about
apartheid now apartheid there are 12
members Israeli Arab members of the
Parliament in Israel fully equal
citizens there's also an Israeli Supreme
Court justice Israeli Arab Supreme Court
justice in Lebanon by the way an Arab
country the Palestinians are not allowed
to have about 60 jobs 60 white-collar
jobs including certain teaching jobs and
lawyers and things of that nature Jordan
which is anywhere from 50 to 80%
Palestinian they're not allowed to run
for certain parts of office because the
king who's supposed to be this great
western guy they know he knows that
they'll just take over if he lets them
have equality they've also been kept in
Palestinians are kept in refugee camps
in Syria by the way 2,000 Palestinians
were killed in Syria in the last two
years starved in the Yarmouk refugee
camp nobody really talks about that you
know and then everyone talks about 1967
that this account this is all about 1967
an occupation that started in 1967 again
a war that was launched on Israel now
maybe they shouldn't have taken any land
after that and they should have said you
know what we can't
kakeland it's not the right thing to do
I think that's a perfectly legitimate
argument that's not really how any other
country in the world works but I think
that's a certainly fine argument but the
idea that this started in 1967 I'm
pretty sure they didn't want the Jews
there before that so there's that so
basically what I think this is really
about is not whether the Palestinians
can have the state the Israelis would
give them a state or not even give it's
not even about give they could have a
state the world wants them to have a
state but I don't think it can come on
the heels of the death of the Jewish
state which is pretty much what Hamas
wants now I know there's gonna be a
zillion comments yelling at me for all
kinds of things that I'm gonna called
all kinds of mean words I hope you
understand that everything I said there
was coming from a place of I want peace
I want there to be two states if the
Arab world would jump into the world of
modernity modernity is that a word if
they would become modern and and care
and do the things that would lead to a
civilized state we could have peace in
six months Israel didn't leave Gaza so
that they could be back there nine years
later having to fight a war I mean
that's just not logical okay so how was
that was that pretty good I normally
don't talk that much here we go
now is this ever gonna stop Malcolm
well first thing I want to I didn't
realize until I looked at the map that
you showed that Israel is the Delaware
of the Middle East that you know poor
Delaware never gets its own you know
there's no room for it and Israel it's
the same thing I you know I you know I'm
pretty sure that the Middle East the
whole israeli-palestinian conflict is
gonna be solved but it's not gonna solve
on this show it's gonna be solved on
Twitter yeah that's my literally it's
gonna be solved but I I follow you on
Twitter and I monitor all your tweets
about it and I don't follow all the
conversations because there are only so
many hours in the day and I but I assume
there's plenty back and forth and lately
since the invasion of Gaza there's been
a tremendous uptick in the number of
comments you've made about how great it
is to be able to block people on Twitter
the button is the one thing keeping me
sane right now because actually I'll
have a debate with people I'm trying not
to have to be with anonymous you have an
anonymous Twitter profile with no name
and just a picture yeah often and I
don't play
yeah and a fight with an egg I don't
fight with eggs I did tweet that I will
not fight with an egg well I'm an
elitist what can I tell you